i want to pull up this story from the
post-millennial
60 of abortion clinics shut down in red
states with pro-life laws after row was
overturned so for those that are
adjusting in we've been talking a bit
about the convention of states a couple
things that i that i think are
interesting here is for one i definitely
want to get into uh your guys's thoughts
on abortion but i was i was i was
thinking about this for one this story
actually uh was a meme
does it mean because people were saying
if planned planned parenthood claims
that most of the services they provide
are unrelated to abortion why would they
shut down when robert way was overturned
and maybe there's some like political
point they make but the mainstream press
came out and said the corporate press
shouldn't call mainstream said that it's
actually not true they're not shutting
down it was just planned parenthood was
like moving funds around well now we see
that a large portion actually did shut
down when abortions became illegal
so i'm curious in this regard one
obviously we'll we'll have you i want to
discuss your thoughts on this stuff but
i was also thinking in terms of
convention of states
would there is it considered limiting of
the federal government to codify a
restriction on abortion or the inverse
to codify the restriction on banning
abortions right because that's what the
left has been arguing for i suppose the
the argument from the left is
the government was restricting its
ability to ban this the argument from
the right is the government was giving
itself the authority over it you see how
there's kind of like both sides are
arguing it's an overreach both sides
would be arguing that their move is a
limitation
i'm curious your thoughts on on that or
it's let's just say it's a it's a hard
segue into the abortion topic but you
know
yeah i mean i would say generally
speaking
if you were to give the federal
government the power to regulate or
allow abortion i mean that's essentially
what dobb said it's like this is not the
federal government's business this is a
true federalist decision it said the
constitution doesn't say anything about
this it belongs to the states so i think
that is the correct constitutional
position and i think any time if if
under our convention you said we're
going to give the federal government
more power to ban abortions
i think you're now expanding federal
power i think either either way it goes
whether it's pro-life or pro-choice it
would be
it would not be eligible under our uh
our rubric and to be clear like i just i
want to give my personal bias i'm
completely anti-abortion me too so here
i am a guy from the right anti-abortion
and i just don't think that that's in
the constitution for the federal
government to deal with and you know
what uh i agree you know um i i like the
idea the problem is
i should say the challenges that you've
got aside that's that's willing to have
the constitution be amended to enforce
their idea absolutely whereas you are
willing to compromise and say we don't
like abortion but let the states decide
i mentioned this quite a bit this is
this is conservatives compromising on
the issue of pro-life versus pro-choice
whereas the left is arguing every state
should have to allow it the right saying
let some decide let's say decide for
themselves so it's split
you're you're this is a this is a real
example
of
why a convention of the states having
the discussion of convention in states
is is important to america because
i think as
what i'm seeing polls go on and people
realize
that the supreme court decision in dobbs
didn't
ban abortion as the left said it did
and that they're there this is a
decision that the people at the local
level and state level can make
more and more people even folks who are
for uh abortion being legal
are are saying well okay i'm comfortable
with that i'm comfortable with me having
to say and what these decisions are and
that's why the argument we're making
with convention of the states is look
let's just re let's just not just
abortion but a whole host of other
issues that are really local issues
education is a good example really do we
need the federal government telling us
how parents should educate and and and
local schools should no
let the community
be able to make these decisions
themselves so we can get an amendment
that says no more department of
education yeah we can absolutely
absolutely i mean that's at the very top
of my list and my job the majority of
the american public agrees with that not
just on the right there's plenty of
people on the left that like hey we want
to educate our own kids our own way
if you live in texas which is where i'm
from right and people think of it as a
red state well i live just outside of
austin that's about as blue as it gets
people in austin want to decide how to
educate their own kids they don't want
the federal government telling them how
to do that
yes i absolutely agree i think um you
know to keep in line with this one of
the things we talk about every so often
is that uh to put it rather i guess
crudely
the left is removing themselves from the
future of america through the
sterilization of their children through
abortion
and so
when you look at education it's the one
venue they have absolutely i say this
all the time that
the left i wrote a book
15 years ago now called it takes a
family it was in response to hillary
clinton's book it takes a village and
one of the things i realized was
everyone said oh it takes a village it's
an african proverb and i said no it's a
marxist plan because the left
through their sterilization abortion ex
they're not having children people on
the left are not having kids so if
they're going to win elections in the
future they have to corrupt your kids
and the way they do that is the village
the village being why do you think they
want to extend expand daycare why do
they they want to expand preschool and
kindergarten and send everybody to
government schools for all these things
they want to separate you from your kids
because they want to separate you from
your kids they want to indoctrinate them
into their point of view and they are
and and that's why do you think the
teachers unions
the the
roosevelt when when the issue issue came
up about unions for uh for federal
workers was a hundred percent against it
and and in fact ultimately and still the
case today
federal unions cannot negotiate wages
and benefits why because they knew that
if if if you give the the uh the rights
of of workers in a in a government
organization the right to to organize
and you gave the power to the governor
the people in the government to to to
enhan to reap benefits on them then the
teachers are going to or the or the
federal employees are going to
shower money on these folks who make
their decision and you're going to have
corruption and you're going to have
control by the union of the government
exactly what's happened in the schools
exactly where we are and and so
the
it is absolutely essential for us to um
you know to fight this battle
there was an um education weekly poll
that came out just after the 2016
election that found that half of
teachers had voted for hillary clinton
but something like 29 30 percent had
voted for donald trump i mean the
occupation is completely
partisan
you aren't sending the same people and
in part i would argue that the home
school movement has such legs especially
after the
code pandemic you know if you're
interested in education especially in
your own children's education in your
conservative you're probably willing to
try homeschooling whereas that's not
true for especially women who have been
told your career is everything if you
have a kid you've got to get back to
work as soon as possible otherwise you
will lose your identity i mean the
system is biased towards the flexible
parents who are willing to stay involved
in their kids lives
yeah we
we have seven children we homeschooled
all of our kids through grade school
it was the best thing my wife is a
neonatal intensive care nurse she's a
lawyer and once we started having
children she phased out of of that work
and
she will tell you that it was the best
investment she's ever made she we have
amazing kids we feel very very blessed
and
i would just challenge anybody
anybody who decided not to do that and
and went to the workplace show me your
portfolio of what you accomplished in
the last 30 years versus what my wife
accomplished in the last 30 years and i
would be you'd be hard-pressed to outdo
what she did this is this is the
craziest thing is that um particularly
on the left they don't understand the
value of an investment in creating a
human life
and it's a really sad prospect of uh
what their lives are going to be like
when they're
70 or 80 years old i i gave a speech in
hungary at cpac hungary a few weeks ago
my first thing i said was
can any of you tell me the name of your
great great grandparents
can you can you tell me the name of your
great great grandparents great great
great great grandparents the point was
in a very short period of time you're
going to be lost your name my great
grandfather right now i'm i'm a great
great yeah okay so the reality is in 100
years or less no one's going to know
your name you know you will be gone and
and the only thing you will create in
your life that lasts forever and and
goes on
is creating a human soul i think and and
and those children then creating other
human souls that's that's your legacy
and so many people
just are have very misplaced priorities
there's this photo i saw i can't
remember exactly how they did it but it
was like
a single grandmother
and then her kids her grandkids and her
great grandkids and each of her she had
like five kids who each had like five
kids who each had like five kids and
it's just insane
how many in fact the impact remember you
you're having these children and you're
raising them and nurturing then you're
preparing them to do the same to the
next generation i mean you you put
yourself into your children and you and
and they can then take what you've given
them and and pour that into their
children and their children i mean it's
got to come out of those schools yeah
the key and the point is the left
doesn't want you to do that they want to
convince men and women not to educate
their children not to fight for the
souls of their children to give them to
them
and they will they will they will
rightly educate your children what you
got to say to them and say if you have a
kid
they could become a child star and then
you're rich
or they can have a lot of followers on
instagram and that will make you feel
immortal forever because as you know
when you retire and you need assistance
your instagram followers will come take
care of it
that's what they're known for check it
out there is going to be
some influencer today they're going to
be childless they're going to be 80 and
they're going to be on instagram which
no one uses anymore it's going to be
like only old people everyone everyone's
on insta talker or something like that
and then we chat yeah on wechat and
they're gonna be like i use
musiplex prunes
you should get yours today and then the
several several they'll probably get
fifty thousand dollars per read because
of inflation of course and then they'll
use that that'll buy them muselex musel
they'll just
yeah i would just say take a step back
and recognize
that this generation last few
generations have been sold this bill of
goods are the most unhappy
depressed generation most medicated
generation in the history of the country
and there is a reason for that because
what you have been sold is a lie
and you just need to get back to the
truth and understand what really makes
you happy i mean i really do hold social
media accountable for a lot of this i
think it gives you a false sense of
community it's not that it can't be a
great tool and it's not that it can't be
very powerful but you know the robert
putnam who wrote bowling alone talks
about this it's just a complete
degradation of community if at the end
of the day you don't know your neighbors
you are not going to be able to call
your many many facebook followers to
help you if you have a crisis with your
kids in the middle of the night or if
you fall and you need help you need to
know the people that you live near i
mean that's the only way to truly feel
fulfilled in life it's a scary prospect
of what the future is going to look like
for a lot of people on the left because
they're going to vote for government to
replace family they've been doing that
that is what they're doing but imagine
what it's going to be like when these
millennials are all older
they're going to be out in a massive
voting block saying the government
should provide for us a young person to
change our diapers or something like
that well i think they're already saying
that and you know when i travel around
the country and i talk to young people
and they look at people our age they're
like hey thanks a lot for the debt or
what did we get for this and and that's
what we've done is we've spent their
future it's pretty outrageous when you
think about it we self-justify that i
say we cause of my age but our
generation we're leaving this incredibly
massive debt it means their taxes are
going to go up their standard of living
is going to go down and if you ask
somebody hey are you willing to do that
to their kids you would say well of
course i'm not that's outrageous it's
immoral but that's precisely what we've
been doing and that's precisely what
democrats are selling to us today
yeah you know i i i don't want to say
that it's
you know you mentioned your age i'm
assuming you guys are both boomers is
that your boomers oh the
no it's it's it's the corruption in
government yeah that it's like the
boomer generation for all this the the
the flack they get from millennials for
like gutting our future it's like yeah
okay okay i'm going to fight back on
that
reason and the reason why i was going to
tell them
that's my point okay go ahead my point
was that you've got corrupt elites in
government who are deficit spending and
selling you a false you know bill of
goods and then
to blame the regular working-class
person is is absurd now the problem is
the elitism that has been selling us out
it before the boomers there were other
people in government it wasn't the
boomers who started the federal regime
okay i'm going to fight back on this
because
those people get elected
because they've convinced the american
public that government can solve their
problems and they believe it yeah and so
you know they're not getting they're not
doing it these aren't people who came
from outer space and are opposing this
these are people that you listening to
this elected
because they promised you something and
you believed it
that's the problem is so i always say
you can point to washington say oh it's
terrible it's so divided
well now we're seeing you know what the
country's pretty divided and they're
just a reflection of that and the same
thing with this deficit spending
they're a reflection of a country that
once material goods and services and
they don't want to pay for them
how many times do you mean how many
things do you want oh i don't want to
pay that much so let's just borrow the
money and that's what's going on so
you can blame washington and i do but
that's why a grassroots movement like
this
that awakens america and has a
discussion about what the consequences
of what we're doing is such an important
thing at this time
i wonder if it's just
just a natural ebb and flow right you
know strong men make good times good
times make weak men you're familiar oh
yeah absolutely and maybe there's
maybe there's no real
it's just something that occurs when
things get good you don't have enough
people who are calloused and hardened to
what's going on
you're trying to wake up a ton of people
to say support a convention of states
there's a good argument about about it
but let the argument happen i suppose
why is the greatest generation the
greatest generation world war ii yeah it
was hard because it was hard yeah i mean
people are made i mean everybody wants
to avoid suffering but suffering is part
of life it's whether you want to suffer
for something that's great and worthy
and last or something that makes you
feel good for the short period of time i
was saying this earlier today that uh
you know people often say like maybe
we're in hell you've heard that i
imagine from some people like maybe
we're actually in hell look how awful
things are and i was like maybe we're
actually in heaven
because you know this world suits us so
well you know it could just be that
we've developed for the world around us
or that we are made for the world but my
the way i see it is
suffering there is no happiness without
sadness there is no light without dark
no the the universe is rather perfect in
that it's a great experience and i
you know it's just about how you you you
you choose to see it i've gone through
some really dark days but i've always
just chosen to be like this is something
that i'll remember and i can always say
i've experienced and learn from i've had
some really bad moments
you know like standing out in a
thunderstorm shoes getting soaking wet
car broke down and i'm laughing like
heck of a story man yeah you know it's
something in life you get to say you've
done i suppose and you rack all these
things up and it just feels
you know whenever i whenever i would
find myself in these really crazy
moments obviously
not being having my life threatened like
those obviously are truly horrifying but
i'm saying in like all the frustrations
of a
car dying in the middle of the road
having to get out in the rain i'm like
those are things that are supposed to be
bad i actually think those are that's
the spice of life you know like you put
you put habanero peppers in your food it
burns but you like doing it